sounds interesting it is because it's
like like she just seems so clearly like
like dumb just doesn't understand
business and like yeah and then the
other dudes the Daves are just like well
here's a receipt for that here's
paperwork showing this here's proof of
that and then she's just like
[Music]
no did you guys hear about the pink
sauce lady from Tik Tok no oh yeah she
was selling some sauce what kind of
sauce kind of a wild story it's a long
tale it's a long taale tell us the tale
pack it in all right so think about it
like this this chick is on Tik Tok she's
she's making food videos where she's
drizzling the food with this like pink
sauce and people are like yo what's the
pink sauce for a while she's not saying
what the pink sauce is and then all of a
sudden she comes out with the pink sauce
now you can buy it from her oo is it
just like Pepto Bisal or something like
that it's like a sweet Ranch okay that's
how it's been described but it looks
like Pepto bis okay I like Pepto bismal
she's sending it to people and then all
of a sudden like after not very long
people start reporting like hey um
something's wrong with this [__] right
many many packages were exploding in the
mail people were getting it saying that
they got sick immediately after having
some pink sauce did she come in it or
something she didn't come in it as far
as I know that's definitely the first
question that most people asked yeah
it's a great question though um is it
because it was exploding that's so e
connected the dots exploding come no
it's because when something's like
contaminated it's usually because of
foul bodily play that's fair or dairy so
um that's technically bodily play or
they just forgot to refrigerate it that
no probably had
cated breast milk she so she's selling
the sauce for you don't acknowledge my
question cuz it's a stupid question you
take the
L I asked the real hard questions 20
she's telling it for $20 a bottle $20 a
bottle okay set an example quickly sells
out the backlash starts and then um she
went live to to address her followers
and they're like hey was this [__] FDA
approved and she's like what do you mean
FDA approved I don't sell Medical
Products you idiots she doesn't know
what FDA is she doesn't know that it
means so she she she just basically
cooked it in her kitchen and just
started selling them yeah she started
Jarred it up and sended it out a lot of
bottles so then in January 2023 of this
year right she announces because I don't
know when this video is Gonna Come Out
She announces that she's partnered with
with a group called Dave's goret and
they they added the Ping sauce to their
portfolio and they paid her a chunk of
money as a fee to like onboard her right
and that would like solve her problems
they got her into FDA approved
facilities wow everything's gucci.com
right now right so then she's in Walmart
she's taking pictures of her holding
pink sauce in Walmart everyone's like
let's [__] go time to fix this story
right so then a couple of of months go
by and in August she takes to her
Instagram and she's like hey I'm [__]
broke she spent all the money she starts
to go fun me and she's like I am being
[__] over by these guys at Dave's
gourmet they basically signed a shitty
deal with me they're taking all the
money they gave me nothing maybe she
didn't read the contract a lawyer she so
this is where it gets interesting yeah
so she is is now has the go I me people
are actually donating to it they but
they believe her fing dumb dude and um
she does not name the company in video
in the video or social media she just
said that it's been difficult for her to
to care for and feed her kids and so and
she's facing eviction she's in trouble
oh man so then after the internet
basically figured out as days Gourmet
started firebombing the [__] out of all
their social media Pages d Gourmet fires
back and says hey we gave her like um a
piece of the $120,000 I think they gave
her like 60 Grand something like that
huge chunk of money for for barely even
being a year in business with her right
not even a year a couple months and then
they're like hey and she's also asking
us for 100 grand so she could have a
birthday party what the [__] yeah she
wanted 100 grand for a birthday party
and she says she was going to film it
and it was going to be for pink sauce
and they're like yeah no sorry no and
then they she wanted to buy a couple
thousand for shoes and stuff like that
and they're like
no and then um yeah so then it gets it
gets um pretty weird W gets pretty weird
because she's like basically saying
that's not true none of that's true and
then they're saying hey um and she's
like they [__] me with the legal
contract and then like hey we actually
um hired we said said we'd pay her
lawyers to explain the contract to her
we we offered to do that dude it's
pretty [__] bad man pretty
wild um so now we're kind of at the at
this point where um D Gourmet is just
sort of like yeah that's that's our
story and then she's just calling them
liars and we'll see what happens wow so
you've been following this too is it
interesting sounds interesting it is
because it's like like she just seems so
clearly like like dumb just doesn't
understand business and then like yeah
and then the other dudes the Daves are
just like well here's a receipt for that
here's paperwork showing this here's
proof of that and then she's just like
no that's that's all she got is Dave
gourmet's page like a corporate page and
then they're actually answering to what
her I don't I don't know how the how it
actually looks like how they're
communicating but I just read the the
whole Saga and a lot of like every
YouTuber that does coverage of stuff is
cover in this so you can get like every
kind of take on it and it's just funny
that like people really just like want
her to be right but it's like dude every
step of the way she kind of was being
stupid it's cuz people always want like
the underdog or stick to the man huh
they probably view yes but in this case
they feel bad for the sauce company like
they're the underdog yeah like this
lady's crazy it's like from the
beginning she had no business trying to
operate it that way like she she made a
cool sauce that people thought was you
know fun but to be jarring it up with no
like Health C or anything and just be
shipping it out to people and it like
the videos of people taking it out as a
globular Mass like just spoiled milk and
dairy and [__] in there it's like how
are you cheering this person on like
they could have she could have killed
you cuz it needs to like have shelf life
right you need to put some stuff in it
you need an expiration day it just takes
so much more than like having the jars
yeah damn and then you got to sanitize
those jars before you fill up with any
Dair how are you buying how are you
buying food from a person who literally
said FDA what's that I ain't selling
medical products like dude what are you
doing Food and Drug Administration yeah
how are they looking at a a situation
where she's [__] obviously [__] up
and sending out like really terribly
packaged and non-approved things and
then going like yeah we should partner
up with her well kind of like the market
because they were the only things she
was missing yeah she had all of the
publicity people really wanted it they
were the only thing she didn't have it
was hot enough to get him into Walmart
with the metrics they had right cuz it
had momentum it really did like oh we'll
produ it for you she just didn't have
business structure yeah yeah as of
today's date Dave's gourmet says that
they have uh sent her more than 120
Grand yeah wow damn it happened in
little chunkies and then I guess like
she keeps saying that like she she
needed money for like airbn bees and
stuff that she's living at she said that
she was homeless and that she needed
more money from Dave's gourmet to pay
for her where she was going to live yeah
but then like people are like why aren't
you just living in an apartment or
something and like I guess she was
saying that she kept staying at like
hotels or something or Airbnb yeah she
was said she was living at a hotels when
she was first selling the sauce yeah so
she wasn't living in a home home that's
what she says we don't know when me and
Joe first got into YouTube and you know
how like people always want to have
meetings and [__] I don't know what the
[__] are all these meetings about just
email us what the [__] you want and
we'll tell you if we're going to do it
or not but then at the more I got older
and like experience and hear about
things like this I'm like oh the main
reason of the meetings is to just vet if
someone's crazy as [__] or not cuz it's
like there's business right and then
there's the who are you and so just
through the talking and stuff it's like
they clearly didn't vet her I'm like oh
I get like I I understand why people
just need to meet and just to see if
they're even like all there because
someone could have a b build ion
followers and then if it's just through
email it's like they could be [__]
coolo dude sweet Ranch sounds really
gross I got to say watching her put this
[__] on pizza made me want to throw up
really looks nasty it just looks
disgusting it looks literally like Pepto
bismo yeah I thought pink sauce was like
you know at the uh Italian places where
they mix a little bit of marinara with
alfredo I thought like that it looks
like something though that when I was a
kid if I saw the Ninja Turtles drizzling
out on a pizza I'd be like oh my god oh
yeah it's pretty cool like Captain like
the Hook movie like when they're having
the buffet it's like rainbow [__] eating
frost all those like different cream
pies of weird ass colors yeah it's super
cool I was on board but now I'm an adult
and I'm like that looks like [__]
diabetes Thousand Islands pink it's a
different kind of pink orange I think no
but like bright pink different in and
out it ain't
pink that's not th000 o though the
In-N-Out sauce is delicious that's
spread oh God it spread that one's kind
of pink dude hearing Bart talk about
food with that little
like that's how I know you're a fat kid
inside I know
it you talk about it but I see it too oh
I finally had a burger yesterday I had
Shake
Shack man how come you finally had a
burger you've been just haven't been on
on my menu for food I've been cooking
more at home you know so okay what sauce
do we put on everything oh dude depends
on what I'm EA I'm not like a one sauce
guy yeah one sauce guy if I if I had to
pick one sauce it be Tabasco oh okay cuz
some people will put the same like
Sriracha on everything yeah I could do
that too I could do so depends on what
kind of food but I do put Sriracha on a
lot of things versus Tabasco I like
Tabasco on like eggs and breakfasty
stuff and I like Sriracha on like you
know anything anything I can also do
ketchup on a lot of things M yeah a lot
ketchup good you should see bar when he
uses ketchup he has ketchup with a side
of hash browns I've seen using he does
ketchup soup that sounds good I like
that soup it's very good sounds really
good he uses ketchup like it's marinara
sauce you guys see me use Tobasco I [__]
it up the same way I'm not a hypocrite
you use a lot yeah you also a lot of Red
Bull yes sir yes
[Laughter]
sir
[Music]
oh